تم تدريب المجندات في أوكرانيا
على
القتال كما تم إجبارهن أيضًا على
التدريب لأكثر من شهر للسير
والحصول على هذا الكعب العالي
تدافع وزارة الدفاع الأوكرانية عن
قرارها بجعل الطلاب العسكريين يتقدمون في
الكعب الشهر
المقبل للاحتفال  30 عامًا من الاستقلال
عن الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق ،
على الرغم من بعض ردود الفعل الشديدة
والغضب من عدد من المشرعين المحليين ،
فإن فرصة ماثيو تعود إلينا من
موسكو ماثيو
يويو لماذا يفعلون هذا
جيدًا ، أعني أنه أمر مؤلم
أليس كذلك  نعم أيضًا للمشاهدة
وكان هناك الكثير من
الانتقادات داخل أوكرانيا من مجلس وزراء
الحكومة الأوكرانية
حول سبب حدوث ذلك ، أعني
أنهم يعرفون أن وزراء الحكومة قالوا
انظروا  هذا أولاً وقبل كل شيء غير مناسب ،
كما تعلم ،
جعل المجندات الذين تعرفهم يستعرضون
في هذا الكعب
أه يقولون إنه لا
يعكس وضعهم القتالي ، تذكر
روسيا هي
قصة أوكرانيا هي دولة في حالة حرب مع
المتمردين المدعومين من روسيا في شرق
البلاد وهناك 57
جنديًا أعتقد
أنه رقم ألف أنثى تقاتل في ذلك
الصراع وأيضًا هناك مشكلة صحية
أثيرت أعني
المسيرة بأحذية مثل التي تعلم
أنها لن تكون جيدة بالنسبة
لك كما تعلم بوضوح ، لذا
هناك سيارة فيراري الهائلة التي تم
تفكيكها من قبل وزارة الدفاع
التي تعرفها في البداية أنها دافعت عنها ،
وتقول إنك تعلم الجيوش الأخرى
في
العالم يصدرون الكعب العالي للجنديات
في زيهم الرسمي ، لكن تم الإشارة أيضًا
إلى أنهم لا
يتوقعون عادةً أن يسير هؤلاء الجنود
في تلك الأحذية ، ولذا
فإن وزارة الدفاع في أوكرانيا
تقول الآن حسنًا ،
انظروا.  سننظر في
هذا الأمر وسنرى ما إذا كان بإمكاننا أن نعرف
العثور على
أي شيء أكثر راحة ،
أعني أنهم على ما يبدو
يتراجعون عن ذلك
ولكنك تعرف ما هي لورا  يوضح t
نوعًا من
مشكلة أوسع تتعلق بأنك تعرف
تصور النساء ،
نعم في أوكرانيا ،
إنه شيء يحدث كما
تعلمون في جميع أنحاء العالم بالطبع
نشهد هذا النقاش حول ما هو
مناسب
للجنود والإناث
بشكل عام  ما هو غير
مناسب تعلم أنه بمجرد أن أجادل
كل الآخرين ولكن أعني أنك تعلم أن هذا
هو التكرار الأخير لذلك في أوكرانيا
والذي
ربما لا تعرفه تمامًا في نفس
المكان في هذا النقاش الذي نحن فيه
في بلدان أخرى في  نعم ،
أعتقد أن هذا من شأنه أن يضعها
بشكل أقل ما يقال في كلمة أخرى لأنها مجرد
التحيز الجنسي الذي يناسب أيضًا